bonjour dominique pradalié vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat national
des journalistes bonsoir plus tôt alors
cette nouvelle manifestation qui est
prévue demain dans tout l'hexagone
il ya eu un choix donc de délocaliser
cette fois la contestation pour quelles
raisons selon vous elle tient la corde
il a décidé de ne pas appeler à
manifester à paris parce que le préfet
de police se révèle totalement
incapables de sauvegarder la sécurité
des citoyens et des biens
alors il ya une c'est une manifestation
en tout cas dans tout l'hexagone qui
s'annonce dans un contexte particulier
puisque il ya une volonté du
gouvernement de revoir sa copie de
revoir donc cet article 24 ce contexte
là justement que faut-il en attendre
demain il n'y a aucune volonté réelle du
gouvernement de revoir sa copie il y a
que des faux fuyants il n'y a que des
leurs il n'y a que des commissions plus
ou moins avortée
il n'y a aucune volonté sinon celle
d'une ardeur liberticide contre les
citoyens de ce pays demain à quoi est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre puisque les
dernières manifestations
contre cette loi sécurité globale on l'a
vu beaucoup de violence en marge de ces
manifestations
beaucoup de violence non il y a eu
quelques violences à paris et à rennes
qui sont en tout cas à paris le fait
désordre contre ordre et mauvaises ordre
du préfet de police
dans toutes les autres villes a été
hyper calme très paisible très serein
très festif
donc il n'y a aucune raison de s'en
alarmer
en revanche nous allons traverser une
période un peu plus confinés et nous
avons jusqu'à janvier pour convaincre
les sénateurs et tous les politiques au
pouvoir du mal fondées eu très mal fondé
de ces textes
il n'y a pas que la loi sécurité globale
il ya aussi le schéma national de
maintien de l'ordre qui est une
catastrophe pour la profession de
journaliste et qui l'un comme l'autre ne
protège pas plus les policiers que les
textes précédents qu'ils sont toujours
pas appliquées d'ailleurs c'est un
mensonge de dire qu'on fait des textes
pour briser les policiers il serait plus
judicieux de poursuivre avec les textes
existants celles et ceux qui les
attaquent
si ces attaques sont bien réels en
revanche il y a quand même sur les deux
dernières années écoulées 200
journalistes 200 empêchés de travailler
ce qui a ému les instances françaises
internationales puisque même michelle
bachelet la haute commissaire aux droits
de l'homme s'en est inquiété
dernièrement après les experts de l'onu
après la commission européenne après le
conseil de l'europe après la défenseur
des droits ce gouvernement devrait quand
même être un peu réaliste et voir que
l'image de la france à l'étranger est
une catastrophe et l'image de la france
que ses ardeurs liberticide
d'autres citoyens
il est encore plus on est quand même
quelques encablures maintenant de noël
cet état de fait justement est ce que
ces manifestations elles vont continuer
jusqu'à ce que ce projet de loi soit
retirée ou penser 1
c'est ce que vous attendez projet doit
être tirée d'une façon ou d'une autre
c'est une évidence
bref on a été coupée non ce projet doit
être retiré d'une façon ou d'une autre
c'est une évidence
de même que doit être retiré le schéma
du maintien de l'ordre et il faut enfin
que des vraies lois existent pour
protéger les manifestants qu'ils
exercent leur droit constitutionnel à
manifester et si on devait réécrire
l'article 24 par exemple il conviendrait
de réclère de la façon suivante seront
punis d'un an d'emprisonnement et de
45000 euros damende de toutes celles et
ceux qui empêcheront des citoyens et les
journalisme de filmer merci beaucoup à
vous dominique pradalié pour avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions vous à
retrouver voilà merci à vous secrétaire
général du syndicat national des
journalistes merci